show so we just wanted to know what is
chippa's favorite moment in history yeah
probably [ __ ] two weeks ago
uh i had this girl sucking my pekka and
uh her friend came over and helped her
out that was two weeks ago that's
probably my favorite point in history
that's it that's a nice thing was that
uh they did that
during during the pandemic that's a
little dangerous to be exchanging
bodily fluids no chip nah they just had
like a little mask
with the [ __ ] glory hole front thing
cut in the front it was very convenient
one was really fat and one was anorexic
and i was driving
and they were fighting over it you know
and the fat one's hitting the other one
and she's puking out the window
but it was about two weeks ago that's my
favorite moment in history that's a nice
moment in history i really like that
chip
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild